along with the number of my colleagues
at Carnegie Mellon I'm really delighted
to participate in the World Economic
Forum it's a great opportunity for
leaders from Carnegie Mellon University
and researchers and faculty members to
showcase their best ideas to thought
leaders and influencers from around the
world at the same time the forum and a
global audience have an opportunity to
see the very best it's coming out of
Carnegie Mellon University and the
impact it has on a global society I'm
really thrilled every year to travel
along with a number of Carnegie Mellon
colleagues so that we can have this
two-way exchange learning from the World
Economic Forum networking with leaders
and talking about all the activities
that go on and CMU to a global audience
you
[Music]